اذا فتحوا ملف الاطفال الاوكرانيين في
الوقت الذي تعاني فيه روسيا من قنبله
ديموغرافيه زمنيه ستجعل من الصعب عليها ان
تشن حربا في المستقبل او المحافظه على
استمرار اقتصادها المتعثر تختلف التقديرات
لاعداد القتلى الروس في اوكرانيا وسواء
كان عشره الاف كما يقول الروس او مئه الف
كما يقول الاوكرانيون فان الرقم لا يبدو
كبيرا في بلد تعداده 145 مليون نسمه لكن
الخبراء يحذرون هنا من ان ارسال الشباب
الى ساحه المعركه بالاضافه الى الهجره
سيؤديان لانخفاض عدد المواليد بعشرات
الالاف وقد شهدت روسيا موجات فيرار جماعيه
لشبابها الموهوبين وحتى النساء الروسيات
سافرنا للخارج للولاده ونيل جنسيه اخرى
ولذا تذهب التقديرات الى ان روسيا قد تشهد
اقل من مليون فاصل اثنين ولاده هذا العام
يعني من مليون ومئتي الف ولاده اذا استمرت
العمليات العسكريه في الاشهر المقبله وهو
الحد الادنى في التاريخ الحديث قسم اخر
يذهب للقول ان روسيا حتى لو كانت خسرت 800
الف مهاجر للخارج بسبب الحرب لكنها في
المقابل كسبت حوالى مليون اوكراني من
المناطق التي ضمتها الحقيقه ان البنيه
العمريه والتعليميه لاولئك الذين هاجروا
منها والذين هاجروا اليها مختلفه تماما
ولا تصبوا في صالح موسكو